[Music]
good afternoon I have the pleasure of
introducing Robert dygraf who is the
director of the Institute of Advanced
Study in Princeton and he will be
speaking about the usefulness of useless
knowledge that's it
Robert the floor is yours good afternoon
it's a it's a great pleasure to speak
here my name is Robert de Graaf I'm the
director of the Institute for Advanced
Study in Princeton which is a famous
institution if only because the first
professor there was Albert Einstein like
to say after that we had 85 years of
steady decline and but I'm also talking
about an essay the usefulness of useless
knowledge that actually appeared it was
written by the first director Abram
Flexner and it appeared in 1939 and of
course we have been discussing today
that the world is kind of a troubling
place but October 1939 it was particular
and he came up with a very forceful
defense of science and scholarship and
let me just read you the first paragraph
is it not curious fact that in a world
steeped in racial hatreds which
threatens civilization itself
men and women old and young detached
themselves wholly or partly from the
angry current of daily life to devote
themselves to the cultivation of beauty
to the extension of knowledge to the
cure of disease to the emulation of
suffering as though fanatics were not
simultaneously engaged in spreading pain
ugliness and suffering and here comes
the world has always been a sorry and
confused
sort of place yet poets and artists and
scientists have ignored the factors that
route if intended to paralyze them I
think this is a very powerful message
that we shouldn't be paralyzed and
should recognize the value of science
actually when Flexner started here the
Institute
first thing he did was not recruit
faculty not design building but ask a
artist to design a logo and have a motto
and the motto was truth and beauty and
it's this I would say we spend in a
scientific community a lot of time
explaining the beauty of our fields and
these days I think we are again
recognizing that truth is equally
important so to explain a flex until you
want to bring you back to the world of
1939 in fact there was the the World
Exposition in New York and the theme was
the world of tomorrow and it was a view
into the future and there were some
tremendous interesting things to see it
was actually the first time television
was introduced to the world I deferred
your opening speech by President
Roosevelt was the first broadcast there
were 300 television sets in the US at
that time was the first fax machine the
first electronic dishwasher and washing
machine and so in many ways it was a
peek into the future in fact there was a
second opening speech was given by
Albert Einstein and he was asked to talk
about the future of science and he spoke
about cosmic rays a kind of esoteric
topic in many ways his talk was a total
disaster
you know the at the moment when he
finished the talk there but there should
be a big light show and in fact all the
fuses blew and the New York Times
reported that the the audience left the
spec for a spectacle they could applaud
but the way it's interesting that his
speech didn't mention two things which
were nuclear physics and computers and
they would totally change the world and
in fact they were happening right at his
own place
in this very small institution that was
funded founded in the in the 1930s in
fact what happened in 1939 of course was
there was a lot of which to research in
particle physics and just after that
opening of the World Exposition Einstein
here wrote with zilart
the famous letter to President Roosevelt
that started the Manhattan Project so
very soon that very esoteric field
became very applicable
a second field that was actively pursued
as mathematical logic people like John
for Norman could girdle Alan Turing and
this incites in the logic of
mathematical proofs let very soon to
building an actual computer for Norman
actually 1940s built the first modern
architectural computer at the Institute
for Advanced Study and at that time of
course this was seen as a very esoteric
subject remarkable thing is that this
machine which by the way only had a
thousand bits of memory was already
being applied by for Norman to many
other fields for instance no he worked
on the hydrogen bomb and so this
institution that was very small and it
was meant to be devoted to pure research
pure basic research as far removed from
reality ten years later we with Albert
Einstein there who was basically the
father of the peace movement there was
phenomen actively working on the
hydrogen bomb and then it was
Oppenheimer with a position in between
so science was incredibly relevant and
in some sense know also at that time in
the 1950s also a victim because of
course as you know Oppenheimer is very
much a source and an active goal of the
McCarthyism now the computer was used
not only for military projects at the
very beginning for Norman so many other
applications so actually the first
computerized very prediction we're done
there at these days that actually took
48 hours to predict tomorrow's weather
so this was a very good sir post diction
the post diction but then there's this
remarkable thing that you know for
Norman is asked to write in 1955 on the
theme can we survive technology and you
might expect that the height of the Cold
War this would all be about nuclear arms
it's not in fact a small fraction of
this piece is about the arms race and
the Cold War but 3/4 is about climate
change and how it could actually be in
his own words climate change he says
will merge
as Nations affair more thoroughly than
the threat of nuclear war you already
realized that in some sense it could
also be kind of a weapon and then I must
say I also find it very comforting that
these final words are then the problems
of future humanity can be resolved not
by single description but rely on some
human qualities as patience flexibility
and intelligence so this is a little
kind of insight of how basic research
has this tremendous opportunity to
transform societies in ways that we
cannot perceive and this is of course a
long story and flexing the gifts
examples it's easy to add new examples
to it think about electricity that
started as kind of a fun game in the
1830s there's this famous quote that
might be apocryphal but that's when the
British Chancellor of the Exchequer
walked into Michael Faraday's Laboratory
knows what's good for he said have no
idea but one day sir you might exit and
of course we did we all pay taxes on our
electricity bills
think about quantum mechanics which
started as a field somehow in
desperation scientists often many very
very young trying to some sense safe
science and you know as Marx Blanc said
he was willing to make any sacrifice to
the principles in physics to to save
science now it's estimated that 30% of
our GDP is based directly based on
quantum mechanics I would actually say
100% of reality is based on quantum
mechanics so everything will do but this
will increase very rapidly certainly
when we have come to computers and other
things so there's mean tremendous
impacts in fact there's something else
which I would like to call the
uselessness of the usefulness of useless
knowledge that not only you get
wonderful applications made and this
application itself lead to breakthrough
work let me mention one thing which is
super conductivity this wonderful
property of materials if you cool them
down that the tricity can basically fall
for free was discovered in the
laboratory of caramely illness and nobel
laureates he was Dutch
one little anecdote he found us by
investing massively in science by
building the first thing he did he built
a school for lab technicians that then
after 10 years produced the experts that
he needed to do with experiments now we
know we have many applications of course
anything that has to do with MATLAB
trains in fact the very strong magnets
you build can be used for fMRI scans and
so they're actually let's do the whole
world of neuroscience modern
neuroscience cannot be perceived without
that discovery and in fact quantum
computers also it plays a crucial role
but perhaps the biggest application is
again in fundamental science so the the
coolest spot on the planet and perhaps
in the universe it's actually the Large
Hadron Collider in CERN where these very
cold magnets are being used to run the
particle accelerator and so the
discovery of the Higgs particle can be
seen as an immediate consequence of this
other fundamental idea that appeared a
hundred years before a century is not a
reasonable long amount of time for a
discovery to see the impact among a very
beautiful result is this year's Nobel
Prize in Physics which recognizes
gravitational waves something that
Einstein predicted more than 100 years
before in fact that you all find your
way here is probably through GPS as you
know GPS wouldn't work would be several
kilometers off each day if you didn't
apply Einstein's special and general
theory of relativity like to say without
Einstein we would all be lost but you
know if you think about the useful basic
research it's it's interesting to see
this I have this meandering River
because it flows in many directions
clearly knowledge is important in and of
itself but also it has these kind of
secondary effects these transform of
these ideas and technologies change our
society they develop new tools and
techniques when particle physicists have
to collaborate worldwide they actually
created the world wide web as a kind of
a social experiment and we all benefited
from that we attract the best minds in
science who
actually many of them go into society
and transform at another possible ways
it drives innovation and startup in a
very spectacular way and and I think
it's truly a public good I think one
reason why we need the science and why
it needs to be publicly supported that
no company no individual no country no
university can capture the goods all of
it it's really something that spreads
across boundaries it's also something
worthwhile the European Commission just
recently calculated an investment in
science drive our well-being
with factors from 5 to 7 the most famous
examples here for MIT it claims it
created 30,000 companies there's almost
5 million employees so there is a real
also practical argument - I would say
invest in basic science to invest in
truth and the most spectacular example
is this small grant of four and a half
million dollars that was given to
Stanford University to develop a search
algorithm in on the internet nor of
course it led to the creation of Google
so if you see the multiplier if you
think of this as an investment it's an
investment of effect of more than
hundred thousand some people make the
idea that you know we could have 99999
government grants that would have failed
and still would have come out positively
on the other hands we see that they're
the investments in basic research are
declining the is more and more is put on
the level of universities and we see
companies retracting from that now I
want to kind of end by saying something
about what drives this search for truth
and I don't want to come back to Flexner
and he writes that it's a the under the
underlying thing is curiosity curiosity
that may or may not eventuate is
something useful and I like to quote
here arthur wellesley the Duke of
Wellington who said that notes you have
to know what's on the other side of the
hill we're talking about truth here but
truth is always evolving and some people
are able to see things that others do
not see in some sense thing you imagine
is the way to peer through the walls and
curiosity is the innate human urge to
climb over the wall and see what's out
there what is the next step and I think
the imagination is incredibly important
thing and I want to end with this little
anecdote this is your Cobras fallen off
he actually was the first Nobel laureate
in chemistry so I always like to say in
1901 the Dutch had hundred percent of
all Nobel prizes in chemistry and he was
the first to realize essentially that
molecules are three-dimensional that the
mirror image of a molecule is not the
same but he made his discovery Humana
announced itself he was criticized and
this is from a famous German chemist
Kolb I said well followed Hoff he made
really leap of the imagination he
climbed on this flying horse Pig and to
Pegasus and basically you went to Mount
Parnassus and this declared how things
were everyone saw was very touched by
this by this criticism and when he was
finally a professor in Amsterdam the
topic of his inaugural lecture was the
power of imagination and he made a
scientific study he looked at a 200 most
famous scientist of the last few hundred
years and put them in three categories
those without imagination no interest in
the arts or poetry or music those with
imagination who love poems who loved
paintings etc and then there's a third
category in his words those with pervert
amount of imagination
those with liked astrology you know all
kind of crazy stuff and these are the
people who in there that's Newton light
needs the cart etc and he makes the
point that you know if you you have this
urge to discover the truth you might be
more by the over-ambitious and might go
to certain areas where orders will not
go and I think that's something that we
have to keep in mind that you know it's
not only if this this this symposium is
about truth it's also about the
mechanism the scientific method but also
the urge to find truth and
that we want to convey as it the same
way as we want to convey the products of
science and want to kind of finish with
design Stein now a quote divine sender
this is all this wonderful anecdote
that's often told that money was a young
boy it got a compass and the compares
like everybody any child is amazed that
the needle always pointed north but then
he describes that he walked with the
confessed to the room and he discovered
something else there was a force
pervasive force through the whole room
which kept the confessed needle pointing
north and in some sense this the
discovery of the magnetic field and is
beautiful because his whole work worlds
and work is about fields etc but it's
also it shows this to you the
imagination of a child and I want to
finish by this wonderful quote that's
one of my favorites of Einstein he had
many that the imagination is more
important than knowledge because
knowledge is limited to all we know and
understand while imagination braces the
entire world stimulating progress given
birth to evolution I would say
imagination is the place where you
really find the future of truth thank
you very much
[Applause]